hello and welcome to this virtual
presentation
thanks to andor for organizing this
meeting and giving us a chance to all
connect as a community and share our
science
my name is ripl arora and i'm a faculty
at michigan state university where i
study early maternal fetal interactions
using mouse as a model system
today i will be telling you about the
insights we have gained from imaging the
implanting embryo
the red circular disc here or the
plasticist
and its immediate uterine environment
in this case the gray structure is the
uterine lumen that holds the embryo
the colorful blooded structures are
uterine glands that provide nutrition to
the embryo before the placenta forms
a little bit of historical perspective
in the earliest times when category
dissections were not permitted by the
church
one had to guess based on outward
appearance or based on animal studies
the hypothesis then was that the uterus
is connected to the breasts
and the uterus is lined by a series of
tentacles or suckers and that's what the
baby feeds on
and when the baby is born it gets the
same nutrition by suckling on the
breasts
later um artists started to collaborate
with clinicians
and would document anatomical structures
in detail
these are pictures by leonardo da vinci
and even still the uterus was always
showed
connected to the breasts then
came the breakthrough advent of
microscopes
that's when we were able to visualize
cellular structure
in detail fast forward to today
we can visualize the mouse embryo or a
mammalian embryo developing
from a two cell stage to a blastocyst
stage
as shown in this movie
the embryo is a transparent structure
and thus can be placed under a
microscope
it's being cultured in a dish under a
drop of oil in media
that's why it's stable and doesn't move
and you can record the whole process
until it forms a blastocyst while this
can happen in a dish in nature it
actually happens
inside the uterine structure this is the
cartoon of a human uterus which has a
single chamber
the uterus has the luminal and glandular
epithelium
the outward layer is the myometrium or
the muscle
and the layer between the epithelium and
the muscle is the mesenchyme or the
stroma
while it's easier to study a small
transparent embryo
it's been very hard to visualize the
uterine structure
for example in the mouse the uterus
is about two to three centimeters long
and about one millimeter thick
both mice and humans and mammals in
general
use the ovary to communicate to the
uterus
the ovary secretes ovarian hormones
estrogen
and progesterone and these hormones bind
to receptors on the uterus
and that's how the uterus prepares for
an incoming pregnancy
just like humans have the menstrual
cycle mice have an easter cycle
on the day of ovulation the levels of
estrogen rise
and then they drop for two days the
levels of hormones stay slow
on day two and a half to three of craig
of the mouse pregnancy
the levels of progesterone start to rise
and there's also a small increase
in the amount of estrogen this is when
embryo attachment occurs
in terms of embryo location it is known
that on the morning of day three
the embryos which are these red circular
structures enter the uterine lumen
which is the greens structure here
and uh the blue here is mesenchyme or
stroma the yellow structures
are histological view of uterine glands
and the red structure is the muscle
these embryos then move through the
uterine horn and somehow evenly separate
uterine contractions are thought to
contribute to the separation of the
embryos
fluid resorption occurs from the stroma
that pushes the wall of the uterine
lumen together
locking these embryos in place and then
they attach
while it is known that these uterine
glands are really important
for delivering secretions to these
embryos how the glands are connected
to the uterus and uterine lumen and the
embryo and how these secretions reach
the embryo is not well known
in terms of three-dimensional or whole
tissue structure
a blue dye can be injected at the time
of attachment or little after
and the site of implantation can be
visualized as a blue dye reaction
in the mouse there are two different
ovarian horns the uterine horns as
opposed to a single uterine chamber
so shown here are the two horns in the
mice that are the ovaries are up at the
top
and the horns are connected down at the
cervix it is interesting to note
that the number of embryos in each horn
can vary
and the spacing between embryos in each
horn is independent of the other horn
for example in this case in the left
horn there are about nine embryos that
are spaced close together
based on the distance that's available
in the uterine horn
on the other hand in the right uterine
horn there are five embryos
and they are spaced far apart compared
to the left the horn on the left
and this is because they have more space
available in this form
so what we want to understand is how
embryos move through the uterine lumen
find a spot for attachment what makes a
good implantation site
and how does the uterine structure
contribute to the embryo finding a good
site for implantation
the methods that we use are removing the
uterine tissue from the mouse
staining for epithelial markers
using amino fluorescence we clear the
tissue
and then use optical imaging in our case
confocal imaging
to image through the whole length and
thickness of the tissue
once we acquire these images we process
them or on our image of analysis
software imrs to recreate 3d structure
and do our quantitative analysis
here are two uterine horns joined at the
cervix at the bottom
the ovaries would be up at the top here
the red is the very tortuous part
path of the uterine lumen and the yellow
structures are the uterine glands
gray is just a nuclear marker that
stains all the cells
so as i said we are able to image the
entire length
and entire thickness of the uterine horn
but in addition we are also able to
recognize
and stain for the embryo
so right here
which is magnified here is the
blastocyst
the inner cell mass is right here the
embryo is attached on one side
while it's still not attached on the
other side on the top right hand corner
is another implantation site
once we acquire these images on the
confocal we process the images
and do a subtraction of signal while we
can stain for all the epithelium and the
glandular epithelium
we don't have a good marker for just the
luminal epithelium so we computationally
remove the glandular signal from the
total epithelial signal
this gives us just the luminal signal
in the next slide i'm going to show you
a 3d reconstruction video
of a segment of a uterine horn we won't
be able to see the muscle because we
have cleared the tissue
and we will be able to see the gland's
colorful structures but when we remove
the glands we will also be able to see
the uterine luminal tube
in blue and this segment can be repeated
over and over again
and i'm going to choose one segment with
one single embryo
the embryo is present somewhere in the
middle and this is as i said a 3d
reconstruction of the 2d
optical slices the blue is the lumen
and hopefully you can appreciate that
the lumen
is very folded as i play the video the
embryo is present in the middle
and the region is pretty flat and we can
quantify the folding
of the lumen when we look at the color
for glandular structures we see that the
structures on the left
are bending towards the middle and the
structures on the right
are also bending towards the middle
where the embryo is present
for the purposes of this talk i will be
talking more about the uterine lumen
and the movement of the embryo
throughout the uterus
so does is the uterus pre-patterned
are the folded and the flat regions
pre-patterned into the uterus
or are they prepared
differently every in every single
pregnancy
in order to figure that out we did a
time course and stained a non-pregnant
uterus a uterus at day two
day three and day four and we saw that
in a non-pregnant and day two uterus
that does not have any embryos there are
folds in the uterine lumen
but they are random at day three the
fold starts becoming very
oriented and patterned and at day four
as i showed in the video
the embryo is present in a relatively
flat region
and it's surrounded by folded regions
when looking back into the literature
there is actually evidence of this kind
of folding
about 20 years ago in a rat study where
the stain the epithelium with alkaline
phosphatase and they saw something very
similar
that at day one their folds are randomly
oriented
at day three the folds are very
perpendicular to the long axis of the
uterus
and at day four the embryo is at the
implantation
site the region is pretty flat and the
region on either side
of the embryo which is also known as the
interim plantation site
is folded in c shapes
we wrote a matlab script to and
integrated it with mrs to quantify
the folding pattern so anything that's
in red
is very folded and regions in blue and
green are relatively flat
so we know that the uterus and the lumen
folds
and the question is is it useful or
relevant or what is the purpose of this
folding
so we went back into the literature and
looked for genetic mutants
where the luminal structure seems to be
disrupted based on 2b
histology the wind 5a raw one
or two signaling pathways seem to fit
this kind of phenotype
in a control when the uterine lumen is
sectioned and stained for h and e
there are these imaginations that run
from the m to the am pole the m is the
mesometrial the top
and the am is the antimesometrial pole
and these imaginations are perpendicular
to the long axis
in the ligand which is meant 5a loss of
function uteri
the patterning is lost and so is it it
is also lost in the receptor loss of
function
as shown here so we decided to acquire
these mutants
and look at these structures in 3d
so as i presented earlier in controls
the lumen
is patterned from m to am and the
uterine lumen folds in a perpendicular
manner
along perpendicular to the long axis
in the ligand loss of function the folds
are actually
along the oviducted cervical axis
and in the raw rundown two losses
function there are fours that are
partially perpendicular and partially
parallel
so the 3d actually reveals that
the ligand and the receptor are having a
different kind of effect
but both of them result in loss of this
or pattern perpendicular force
the authors of the paper have shown that
both in the ligand
and in the receptor loss of function
pregnancy is lost
around day 10 or 11 but
perhaps the cause of loss of pregnancy
is the defective events at the time of
implantation
currently we are exploring how a
appearance
in the folding pattern can affect the
embryo attachment and implantation
and how this could lead to poor
pregnancy outcomes
next we wanted to investigate how does
the embryo move
through the uterine horn and how it
finds the site for implantation
so as i mentioned earlier it is known
that embryos entered the uterine horn on
the morning of day three
so we decided to run a time course and
collect fixed tissue
on the day three of pregnancy at regular
intervals
so this here is a video of optical
slices
collected from a midnight sample on the
morning of day three
this right here is the ovary this is the
oviductal euthrone junction
and then that's the length of the uterus
the movie will zoom into this portion
which is the presumed
oviductal uterine junction and the
optical slices
will display the location of the embryos
because we stayed with ecad we can tell
that this
is patterned oviductal epithelium and
the embryos these circular structures
are all present in the oviductal side of
the oviductal uterine junction
the c-shape here is the beginning of the
uterus
and none of the embryos are delivered
into the uterine
lumen yet also note that the oviducted
lumen
is open if you look
at the three hours later
three hours later the embryos are
collected in the uterine lumen
and the oviductal junction closes
so we collected many many uteri
at all these different time points and
i'm going to collectively show the data
in this graph
each circle here is an embryo and
circles in the same line
are embryos that were found in the same
uterine form
the number here represents the number of
neutron horns that we have looked at
so on the morning
of day three at midnight the embryos are
either in the oviductal or in the
uterine part of the oviductal eutron
junction
three hours later they are delivered and
they are in the early part
of the uterus the embryos start to move
mostly in clusters by 9 am
all the embryos arrive in the middle of
the uterine horn and stay there in
clusters
they are still there in clusters at noon
at 3 pm half of the horns have started
to scatter
whereas the other half still remain
clustered
at 6 pm all the horns begin to plus
scatter and separate in both directions
spacing starts to acquire evenness at 9
pm
at midnight on the morning of day 4 the
embryos begin to attach
and by 6 pm on day 4 they start to show
a blue dye reaction as i had shown very
early on
so we classified visually these the
movement of the embryo in three stages
embryo entry unidirectional movement
of embryo clusters and then a
bi-directional movement that causes
scattering
and eventual spacing of the embryos
followed by embryo attachment
while we individually classify this we
wanted a more robust method
of classifying the movement of the
embryo so we did two kinds of
measurements
we measured the distance between the
embryos
and we also measured the distance
between the embryos
and the oviduct so the blue
color represents earlier stages on the
morning of day three
white represents midday stages
and red represents um evening and
attachment and post attachment time
points
so when we plot the distance between one
embryo and the next embryo
or the oviduct and the embryo we get
this plot
what we see is using k-means clustering
that there are three clusters
either when the embryo embryo distance
is low
and the oe the oviduct embryo distance
is low
that's the entry phase then there are
uteri that are in a stage where the
oviductal embryo distance begins to
increase
but the embryo resistance stays very low
and that's the unidirectional
clustered movement space phase
and then the third cluster is
when embryo embryo distance starts to
increase and oviduct
embryo distance is also high when we
take all the embryos post attachment
and plot embryo ember distance mean
along with the number of embryos in the
horn we get a very good correlation
this suggests that implantation sites
are not predetermined they are actually
determined
once the number of embryos are counted
in a non-pregnant uterus there are no
predetermined implantation sites
another thing we wanted to test is the
embryo embryo distance and the
coefficient of variation
of the embryo embryo distance what we
learned from there is that when the
embryos enter
initially and when they are moving
initially in the first phase
the distribution can be random but as
the embryos
approach the implantation attachment
time points
and after that the distribution of
embryos
cannot be explained by a random event
which means
there is an organized way to distribute
the embryos
along the uterine horn now this kind of
distribution
can either be due to uterine function
embryo uterine interactions or embryo
function alone or it could be that all
three of these factors contribute to
this organized distribution
or the non-random distribution of
embryos along the uterine horn
since contractions uterine muscle
contractions have been proposed
to allow for embryo movement we wanted
to figure out
if muscle contractions are responsible
for all these different movements
in order to do that we decided to use a
muscle relaxant
so as i showed previously at 3 am the
embryos are right outside the oviductal
uterine junction
in clusters we decided to relax the
muscle at this time
and evaluate the location of the embryos
about 12 hours later
the muscle relaxant was given twice in
order to keep the muscle
relaxed over the period of 12 hours
if the embryos are affected by the
muscle relaxant
and unable to move they should be stuck
right outside the oviduct
but instead if the embryos are not
dependent on muscle contractions for
this first phase of movement
they should either be as clusters in the
middle of the horn or they should be
scattered
along the horn
we saw that with vehicle treatment the
embryos were either clustered in the
middle of the horn or
they were scattered along the horn
but with the treatment of muscle
relaxant most of the embryos were
present in the first third of the
uterine
form this suggests that the first phase
of movement the unidirectional clustered
phase
is dependent on muscle contractions
in order to test if the second phase of
movement is dependent on muscle
contractions
we decided to give the muscle relaxant
once the embryos arrived in the middle
of the horn that is around
noon on day three and then we evaluated
the location about eight or nine hours
later
we saw that in both vehicle treatment
and muscle relaxant treatment
embryos were able to scatter and space
along the uterine horn
this suggests that the second phase of
embryo movement
is independent of muscle contractions
in order to investigate what might
affect or impact the second phase
of embryo movement we search the
literature
for genetic mutants that might suggest
a lack of one of these movements
we came across the lpr3 lpa lpr3
signaling pathway
lpa is lysophosphatic acid and binds to
receptor 3 specifically in the uterus
when this gene is deleted and controlled
embryos are transferred
the embryos are not able to space out at
the time of attachment
and instead of scattered or having these
um clusters or overcrowded clusters
along the uterine horn they tend to
um overcrowd near the cervical portion
and near the cervix
so we decided to again look into these
mutants
and this is at the time of attachment so
later on day four
so the question is can these embryos do
first movement and
do they get stuck before the second
movement
so when we evaluate the location of
embryos in these mutants
and their littermate controls at about
noon
about most about 60
of the embryos are stuck in the middle
and in the knockout
the embryos are stuck in clusters either
in the middle of the horn
or near the cervical segment so we
use this three segment distribution
method to figure out if the
embryos were in the middle or towards
the cervix
so the embryos can move in the first
phase they remain as clusters
but instead of stopping in the middle
they tend to go a little bit past the
middle
however these embryos then stay stuck
there while the controls can scatter and
space out
by 6 pm or 9 pm on day 3 the knockouts
tend to stay
as clusters either in the middle or in
the cervical portion
this suggests that for the
unidirectional clustered phase the lpa
lpr-3 signaling pathway
fine-tunes the movement and prevents the
embryos from going past the middle
but later for the second phase of
movement the bi-directional scattering
and
spacing phase the embryos in the lpr3
knockout cannot absolutely move in that
phase
so it is absolutely essential for the
second phase of the movement
to summarize we see that there are two
kinds of movement
for the embryos along the oviductal
cervical axis
a unidirectional flustered movement and
a bi-directional scattering or spacing
movement
along the uterine horn this leads to
eventual movement of embryos to the
anti-mesometrial pole
and implantation
smooth muscle contractions contribute to
the first phase of movement
and lpa lpr-3 contribute to the
bi-directional scattering and spacing
along the overductive cervical axis so
the second phase of movement
in order to understand what tiles
both the folding that i also showed you
in the first part of the talk which is
essential for embryo implantation
and these movements we are currently
investigating how
ovarian hormones estrogen and
progesterone regulate
the folding and or the muscle
contractions to regulate the movement
finally now that we have understood and
quantified the patterns of movement in
the mice
we wanted to compare it to other mammals
and their known patterns
so from the literature we summarize that
in both rats and rabbits
embryos start out as clusters but
the clusters begin to scatter as they
move unidirectionally along the uterine
horn
on the other hand our data shows that in
mice the embryos move to the center of
the horn
and spend some time there before they
bi-directionally space out
this is an important phenomena and it
says that evolutionarily different
species may have adapted
by different mechanisms to achieve
embryos say even embryo spacing
understanding how hormones regulate
the separation and spacing of the
embryos
is essential because this can help us
understand
and probably modulate movement of
embryos when for example they are
transferred back into the uterine space
in ivf and so
currently we are investigating how
hormones can impact the movement pattern
of embryos in mice
i would like to thank my team the
folding part of the
uterine horn that part of the project is
being conducted by a graduate student
manoj madhavan
the project on embryo movement which is
now under revision
was conducted by a talented research
assistant diana flores
thank you